okay we can't say we goofed up and
they're all fired because then the trans
Community will say we're horrible and
bigoted and all of that and so I mean
not even though that this is here's how
I imagine the meeting goes down they
they tell everybody look we understand
you're concern we're gonna have a
meeting in DC come meet and they all
walk in there's a guy in his suit and he
goes listen our customers are dumb as
dumb guests they are so stupid so here's
what we're gonna do We're Not Gonna
apologize We're not gonna say anything
we're going to completely ignore all of
them and let it all blow over that's
that's what they're saying right now I
mean I I don't know if it's quite that
extreme but they are definitely trying
to be like they're definitely trying to
run away from it as opposed to
addressing it and saying the story and I
do think that that apologizing uh is
appropriate because they it's they're
they're they're they're seeing a a
distinct reaction from their their user
base from their their customer base
that's what brands are built on